okay so now we're going to look at
another woke children's book this one
on the surface i mean literally reading
the book by its cover
it seems maybe not as bad as some of the
others that we've that we've looked at
uh that we've reviewed but you never
know so we just kind of uh we're gonna
read this whole thing it's pretty short
and i'll read the whole thing and then
i'll offer my review so let's get into
it this is called
c is for consent and this is um
it says ages this is for ages zero and
plus so if you have a zero
year old child they could they could
read this and not from there i mean you
know it's a board book it's short so
this is really for
kids probably you know two three four
five years old
all right it says it's time for a party
with family and friends
and you see of course there we've got uh
the interracial gay couple we've got the
interracial
disabled cup well one one member of the
couple's disabled you got to get all the
representation there
and um that's i don't see any furries
i don't see anyone who's apparently
transsexual or even transgender
uh or pansexual so that's that's a
problem but we'll keep going
grandma wants a hug but finn isn't in
the mood
that's okay says dad you don't have to
give hugs if you don't want to
grandpa leans down to kiss finn mom says
please ask for consent first grandpa
asks may i kiss you on the cheek finn
replies
hmm yes you may
auntie and uncle want finn to sit with
them come sit on my lap
no you have to sit on my lap finn says
no thank you
my parents say i don't have to sit on
anyone's lap if i don't feel like
it what a brat this kid is
mom's friends give finn a present does
that mean he has to hug or kiss that
person
only if he wants to maybe finn could
high five or fist bump instead or maybe
he doesn't want to be touched at all
it's his choice what happens to his body
finn is happy to see his best friend rue
he asks may i hold your hand
it is okay for you to say no rue replies
yes you may hold my hand thank you for
asking first
[Music]
and that's it that's the end of the
whole story okay then there are
discussion questions at the end which we
won't
get into well so that that actually is
somewhat surprisingly this
is the worst one yet i think this
somehow manages to be more disturbing
than um you know books that are pushing
transgenderism and bisexuality and all
that kind of stuff
those books are bad too but don't get me
wrong but this one disturbs me
on a deeper level so let's count the
ways
to begin with before we get to the major
problems here
this kid is awful i mean this is what
happens when you have
permissive hippie parents i i would not
i can't imagine if i was a little kid if
i was like six years old
and my grandmother came to visit and
said hey give me a hug and i said no i
don't feel like it granny
i cannot imagine what my dad's reaction
would have been it would not have been
pleasant i can tell you
my reaction with my own kids wouldn't be
pleasant and that's a joke yes i tell
them i guess i
viola i've got let me tell you something
i violate
my kid's consent all the time in the
sense that i
force them to do things they don't want
to do sit down and study
that's much of the day in fact is is
involves them doing things
that it's not their idea to do those
things they don't really want to do
those things uh i mean clean their room
let's start with that
look i don't get their consent for that
is what is that forced labor is that
slavery
my kids know that when a family member
comes over to visit you go and give them
a hug
it's not an option it's not a choice you
are required to do that
don't look at me like i'm freaking
frankenstein give your father a hug
because that's polite but
the major problem here is that the book
explicitly sexualizes physical contact
between family members i mean this
author
is he he is well he oh it's who is it
eleanor
morrison he his her whoever's
they're they're taking their own i don't
want to misgender them
whoever it is they're taking their own
complex and projecting it onto everyone
else i don't know what's going on with
you
that you view a hug from an aunt or a
grandfather as potentially sexual in
nature
but it's something you should be talking
to a therapist about you don't write it
into a children's book
for god's sake this is what you get from
the left right they grew up on a diet of
freud whether they know it or not
and now they see everything in sexual
terms everything is sexual
they're incapable of conceptualizing any
human interaction that might occur
outside of a sexual framework everything
for them is sexual or potentially sexual
and uh there are weirdos in other words
to summarize losers in other words i
mean let's even let's take the family
dynamic out of it for a second just uh
just for a moment
because i don't want to dwell on that
it's too disturbing and let's pretend
that we're talking about just some dude
and uh
a girl and they're not related even in
that context
the idea that verbal consent should
precede
every physical interaction is asinine
i mean my wife would look at me like a
maniac
if we were walking somewhere uh down the
sidewalk or something and i said excuse
me
may i have consent to hold your hand
requesting permission to initiate
physical interaction
permission granted you may maintain
physical contact for 75 seconds
thank you man that's what they want now
we know why leftists are so angry all
the time they're lonely nobody wants to
be around them because this is
they act like some bizarre mix it's the
weirdest mix
of hedonistic sex fiend and robot
you wouldn't know perversion if it put
clamps on your testicles
leftist men in particular are just
lonely there's no way any woman wants to
be around
this kind of thing if they carry on like
this all of this hyper consent stuff
it makes us it makes it make sense among
machines
but for organic creatures we need
organic interactions we need things to
develop naturally
but this all again this this is i'm i'm
talking now about two adults who aren't
related
so i'm doing the book a favor by framing
the conversation this way what the book
is actually talking about again
our little kids and their grandparents
they want robotic consent requests even
in that
context excuse me young one may i have
consent to kiss you on the forehead
and squeeze your cheeks and remark on
how big you've gotten since i last saw
you two months ago
permission denied get lost
that is literally the future the left
wants
and i say no thanks